it's the 75th anniversary of d-day you
tube cracks down on steven crowder
another content creators and nancy
pelosi says she'd like to see president
trump in jail lock him up
i'm ben shapiro this is the ben shapiro
show we were tending to get to today on
the show before we get to any of it
first when the founders crafted the
constitution the first thing they did
was make sacred the rights of the
individual to share ideas without
limitation by their government this is
pretty important as you'll see from
today's show the second right they
enumerated was the right of the
population to protect that speech and
their own persons with force you know
how strongly I believe in these
principles I'm a gun owner owning the
rifles an awesome responsibility
building rifles is no different started
in a garage by marine vet more than two
decades ago bravo company manufacturing
BCM for short builds a
professional-grade product which is
built to combat standards I mean it is
very important they own a gun and not
just a gun that works but a gun that
works when you need it to work bravo
company manufacturing is not a sporting
arms company they design an engineer
manufacturer life-saving equipment they
believe it's their moral responsibility
to give you a tool that will not fail
the end user when it's not just a paper
target but somebody coming to do them
hiring a lot of folks who talk about the
Second Amendment and gun manufacturer
they talk about hunting or sport
shooting the folks at BCM understand
that the real purpose of having a gun is
to prevent somebody from encroaching
upon your rights or coming to hurt you
and this is why the folks at BCM take
their job really seriously to learn more
about bravo company manufacturing head
on over to bravo company MFG comm you
can discover more about their product
special offers upcoming news that's
bravo company MFG comm if you need more
convincing find out even more about BCM
and the awesome people who make their
products at youtube.com slash bravo
company USA awesome folks at a great
product youtube.com slash bravo company
USA for more information alrighty so
today marks the 75th anniversary of
d-day one of the great pieces of
evidence that america is an incredible
country frankly d-day the heroism of
young men men who are now half my age
who walked on to beaches who crawled
onto beaches in order to fight off nazis
in order to fight off fascism people who
disdains and abused human rights people
who wish to dominate a content with an
evil a countenance with an evil ideology
the unbelievable
Avery and sacrifice to these people that
day they did more than I will do my
entire life and I had the privilege of
sitting down last Sunday with four
members of the US military at the time
of d-day who talked about their
experiences one of those men that we sat
down with on our Sunday special you can
listen to it over at YouTube or if you
download the show the one of those men
is the guy who you've seen on the news
who's parachuting in at the age of 97
Tom Price the time race rather a really
really good guy obviously well one of
the other folks that that sat down with
us was a fella named Jack Buckman I want
to play a little bit of the Sunday
special because when you hear what these
men went through in order to preserve
our Liberty it should remind us how
precious those liberties are and how
heroic so many have been in defense of
those liberties oh yeah
I stopped by these Saudi I saw body
Underland out on the beach body parts
all over and it was so tough to well I
may be confronted I've seen blood and so
forth in other things but I tell people
have you seen Saving Private Ryan well I
just kind of kind of double that a
little bit because the one thing all
Private Ryan didn't show us all the body
parts laying around and then my mind was
flashing through there's the son a
father that won't be coming home that
was the sacrifice that was made on that
day to preserve our freedoms that
particular veteran Jack Guttman then
went on to serve the Battle of Okinawa
as a medic I mean just enormous heroism
of this entire generation that went
overseas to fight for America's
constitutional liberties here at home on
a read you the order that General Dwight
Eisenhower who's the head of the Allied
forces sent on the day of June 6 1944 to
give a little bit backstory for people
who don't know you know why all this
happened France fell to the Nazis in
1940 this is from archives gov the
Allies planned a cross-channel invasion
on the German
occupying forces ultimately codenamed
Operation Overlord by May 1944 almost
2.9 million Allied troops were amassed
in southern England whose largest Armada
in history made up of more than 4,000
American British and Canadian ships and
more than 1200 planes against a tense
backdrop of uncertain weather forecast
disagreements and strategy and related
timing dilemmas Eisenhower decided
before dawn on June 5th to proceed with
Operation Overlord later that same
afternoon he scribbled a note intended
for release accepting responsibility for
the decision to launch the invasion and
full blame should the effort to create a
beachhead on the Normandy coast failed
this had not been the first attempted
invasion of the coast of the coast of
Normandy actually there was something
called the Battle of Dieppe that had
happened a few months earlier which was
sort of an experimental attempt to see
what would happen in case of an
amphibious invasion it was deliberately
designed not to become a beachhead it
was deliberately designed to learn I
mean that in itself is worthy of an
entire episode the Battle of Dieppe much
more polished in his printed order of
the day for June 6 1944
than his original order he originally
scribbled a note intended for release
accepting that responsibility here is
what he wrote to all of the men who were
about to invade the most heavily guarded
area basically on planet Earth
here is what Dwight Eisenhower wrote he
wrote soldiers sailors and airmen of the
Allied expeditionary force you're about
to embark upon a Great Crusade toward
which we have striven these many months
the eyes of the world are upon you the
hopes and prayers of liberty-loving
people everywhere March with you in
company with our brave allies and
brothers-in-arms on other fronts you
will bring about the destruction of the
German war machine the elimination of
Nazi tyranny over the oppressed peoples
of Europe and security for ourselves in
a free world your task will not be an
easy one your enemy is well trained well
equipped in battle hardened he will
fight savagely but this is the year 1944
much has happened since the Nazi
triumphs of 1940 and 41 the United
Nations have inflicted upon the Germans
great defeats in open battle man-to-man
our air offensive has seriously reduced
their strength in the air and their
capacity to wage war on the ground our
home fronts have given us an
overwhelming superiority in weapons and
munitions of war and placed at our
disposal great reserves of trained
fighting men the tide has turned the
free men of the world are marching
together to victory I have full
confidence in your courage devotion to
duty and skill in battle we will accept
nothing less than full victory good luck
and let us all
beseech the blessing of Almighty God
upon this great and noble undertaking
from the battle itself was absolute
carnage absolute carnage the t-they
beach landings were chaotic and bloody
if you ever watch they've been private
ryan' or he watched a movie couple
longest day you can see what this was
like at least in mild effect the first
wave of landing forces suffered terrible
losses particularly US troops at Omaha
Beach and the Canadian divisions of Juno
Beach according to history calm
thanks to Rob perseverance and grit the
Allies overcame these grave initial
setbacks and took all five Normandy
beaches by nightfall On June 6 the
Germans were so stunned by the attack
that they had not fully mobilized to
defend the coast they thought that it
was actually a feint the first allied
cemetery in Europe was dedicated just
two days after the d-day invasion on
June 8 1944 again I refer you to the
Sunday special we just did last week in
which I interviewed one of the men who
was in charge of graves like it was his
job to bury men and ship bodies back
home since that day military officials
and memorial organizations have tried to
come up with a definitive account of a
lie d-day deaths in order to properly
honor those who made the ultimate
sacrifice according to the National
d-day Memorial Foundation
there are four thousand four hundred and
fourteen names enshrined in bronze
plaques representing every allied
soldier sailor Airman and Codes got a
Coast Guardsman who died on d-day that
figure was the result of years of
exhaustive research John lung who's the
director of Education says when the
memorials first being planned in the
late 1990s there were wildly different
estimates German casualties on d-day
were somewhere between 4,000 and 9,000
killed wounded or missing the Allies
captured 200,000 German prisoners of war
thousands of troops perished during the
initial phases of the month-long
Normandy campaign now it's pretty
astonishing today I mean just shows you
where the head is at for for the Russian
government the Ministry of Foreign
Affairs for the Russian government put
out a tweet saying the d-day basically
didn't matter that what actually
mattered was the the Eastern Front
well the Eastern Front mattered an awful
lot obviously the Red Army holding back
Hitler was an enormous factor and
Hitler's eventual loss but let's recall
that the Soviets were on the side of
Hitler all the way up and told the point
that Hitler actually invaded the Soviet
Union the Soviet Union was being held up
by lend-lease materials provided by the
United States the United States was
fighting off Japan
which was at the other flank of the
Soviet government so when people
discount the contribution of the United
States in World War two they are just
being fully dishonest as the Russian
government is today obviously the
contributions of the United States to
Victory in Europe cannot be overstated
the contributions of the British and the
Canadians and the Australians and all
the Allied forces to the to the Victory
in Europe cannot be overstated and the
contribution of folks who were not even
accorded their full rights in the United
States yet and there are a lot of folks
today who are rightly paying tribute to
the Tuskegee Airmen yeah Charlie has a
great thread over at Twitter talking
about the Tuskegee Airmen who went off
to fight the Nazis even though they were
still subjected to segregation and
racism because obviously segregation was
still a part of American life in really
deep and abiding ways and the reason
that so many people went to fight the
Nazis even people who are marginalized
in American society is because they
understood that the promise of America
was great and important and worth
fighting for and that the rights of the
Constitution and the dreams of the
Declaration of Independence are good and
true and eternal and those things had to
stand up in the face of withering fire
from evil regimes ranging from the
Japanese Imperial Empire to Nazi Germany
now that's a heroism that obviously we
need to always remember and continue
celebrating particularly as the the
greatest generation dies off I mean
unfortunately it's it's hard to find
World War two veterans these days
because many of them are so old there
are very few remaining survivors from
the beaches of Normandy that's why I was
such a privilege to speak with some of
them on the Sunday special we should
remember that we should also remember
that there are people who are committing
acts of great heroism today the members
of the US military today are no
different than the members of the US
military back then when I talked with
these veterans of Normandy about America
and I said what's your hope for America
they always pointed to the members of
the US military today who are
volunteering in who are doing something
that I was not brave enough to do the
these are these are people who are doing
something incredible every single day
and we should take off our hats to those
folks
you should pay tribute to those folks
because they are standing in the
tradition the greatest tradition of
America which is standing for freedom
ready to answer freedoms call with their
life if need be America remains the
great liberator
America remains the great beacon of
light d-day is a reminder of that a
democratic Germany is a reminder of that
a France that doesn't speak German is a
reminder of that the existence of a
Jewish population on planet Earth is a
reminder of that ok anywhere that people
live free it's basically as an effect of
the presence of the United States on
this earth d-day is a reminder of that
thank God for the United States thank
God for the men and women of the United
States who are brave enough to stand for
values thank God for a United States
that continues to maintain the highest
traditions of Liberty I'll get to a
little bit more of this and then we will
get to the other news of the day first
let me tell you something about personal
security so I am deeply concerned about
personal security I received death
threats on a regular basis just a few
weeks back the FBI arrested somebody for
making death threats against me among
other people and that's why I take my
home security incredibly seriously which
is why I work with ring rings mission is
to make neighborhood safer you might
already know about their smart video
doorbells and cameras that protect
millions of people everywhere ring helps
you stay connected to your home anywhere
in the world so if there's a package
delivery or a surprise visitor you'll
get an alert you'll be able to see hear
and speak to them all from your phone
that's thanks to HD video and two-way
audio features on ring devices as a
listener you have a special offer on a
ring starter kit available right this
moment with a video doorbell motion
activated floodlight camp the starter
kit has everything you need to start
building that ring of security around
your home all you have to do is go to
ring.com slash pen that is ring.com
slash pen I love my ring video doorbell
among its other products and I know
then when I'm away from home and
somebody rings the doorbell I can pick
up my phone and see exactly who is there
determine whether this person is somehow
a problem or not ring.com slash man go
make your house more secure go make your
home more secure build that ring of
security ring calm slash Ben for a
special deal ring calm slash Ben okay so
president Trump was speaking in Normandy
on d-day and he gave what I thought was
a terrific speech in Normandy he's again
media malfeasance is so ridiculous so
the media tried to suggest today and the
president Trump was the reason that he
who's doing the interview on Fox and
this was supposedly the reason why he
why the activities went off late that
the activities were supposed to go off
at a particular time they did not go off
at their proper time because
supposedly trump was delaying everything
so he could do an interview on fox and
then later they mentioned oh yeah by the
way Trump finished that interview on Fox
and Emmanuel macron the president of
France still had not arrived so his
really McCrone who was late it was not
Trump who was late okay the the original
tweets about this that it was Trump who
delayed d-day at the ceremony at d-day
because I guess he doesn't care enough
he's just in it for the Fox News and all
this that stuff went viral
obviously the follow-up clarifying that
it was not Trump's fault that activity
started late that didn't go nearly as
viral well done by our journalistic
firefighters once again anyway President
Trump gave what I thought was a very
very good speech on d-day in Normandy
75th anniversary today as we stand
together upon this sacred we pledge that
our nation will forever be strong and
United we will forever be together our
people will forever be bold our hearts
will forever be loyal and our children
and their children will forever and
always be free well again president
Trump is right there thank God as always
for the United States of America thank
God for the United States of America
d-day is a great reminder of that it's a
reminder that we ought to be the kind of
Americans worthy of fighting for that
our rights are worth preserving that the
constitution of the United States which
was the oath that Americans swore to
uphold that that that Constitution is
worth protecting and defending the
rights in the Constitution ought to be
viewed as sacrosanct and that our era of
grave sensitivity I think needs to be
held up against the heroism of past
generations and against the heroism of
today's members of the military who are
out there defending our rights to be
idiots every single day okay meanwhile
in other news speaking of the the sort
of era of sensitivity YouTube is now
cracking down on any creator who offends
at somebody this is basically what we
have learned over the past 24 to 48
hours you don't have to violate
YouTube's Terms of Service in order for
them to penalize you if you whine enough
so if you whine a lot you can get
YouTube to pull down creators videos
thousands of creators videos if you
whine a lot and claim that you are a
victim and suggest that you are being
harassed
well then you know your wine eNOS is
bravery your wine eNOS is great this was
pushed by a guy named Carlos so
Carlos masa is a commentator and
basically an activist over at Vox he
used to work for Media Matters which
tells you exactly what he sees his job
as being the fact that he is considered
a journalist is ridiculous he is not a
journalist he's an activist he's a
pseudo journalist and so he has been
pushing this idea that steven crowder a
person with whom i am friend he's a
comedian
I don't always love everything that he
says in the pursuit of comedy but he's a
comedian and he has made fun of Carlos
Mazda by doing something that he does on
a routine basis to many people every
time I'm on his show he makes Jewish
jokes he calls his lawyer half asian
lawyer bill Richman he talked about he
had a producer named Jared he's called
him not gay Jared he has a producer who
he calls quarterblack
I can't member name of his producer like
this is just a running stick on his show
well he referred to Carlos masa as a as
a as a queer okay so the reason that I'm
saying the word is because I'm not sure
exactly what the context is for when
this is appropriate like Carlos Mazda
calls himself queer but if steven
crowder says the word queer then it's
obviously some sort of insult according
to Carlos Massa so I'm not sure what the
rules are cuz the rules change every
five seconds or so suffice to say I
would not say that about Carlos Mazda
because that's not a word that I used
even if Carlos Mazda uses the word about
himself in any case how do those Mazda
cut together a bunch of clips of steven
crowder making fun of him because steven
crowder makes fun of humans and Carlos
Mazda then complained that this amounted
to harassment it does not if people
making fun of you amounted to harassment
I would be deeply harassed every day I
am NOT people are just basically making
fun of me and that's fine I mean you
want to make fun of me enjoy I'm in the
public square that's the price of being
in the public square get over it girl
with thicker skin so Carlos Mazda
couldn't take it so he started tweeting
about how steven crowder was harassing
him and how he should be ripped down off
of youtube and youtube then replied and
they said we take allegations of
harassment seriously they said our team
spent the last few days conducting an
in-depth review of the videos flagged to
us and while we found language that was
clearly hurtful the videos as posted
don't violate our policies we've
included more information below to
explain this decision so then they
explained there was nothing harassing
there okay and then Karl
Mazal wined an awful lot and a lot of
his allies at Vox this journalistic
firefighters so much journalism in over
at Vox they whined about it to the folks
is the daily beast whined about at the
Washington Post whined about all these
journalistic firefighters who say the
president Trump is trying to crack down
on the press really weird suddenly their
interest in the First Amendment went
completely out the window their interest
in basic free speech principles went out
the window now let me make a distinction
because folks don't YouTube is a private
company the First Amendment does not
apply to YouTube however YouTube says
that it is an open forum YouTube says in
its policies that unless you are
actually targeting someone for
harassment
almost who are actually threatening
somebody they cannot ban your videos so
YouTube held to its own standard
originally and then Carlos went
on a rant and basically because he rands
hadn't wind a lot and suggested that
YouTube was now anti-gay for allowing
steven crowder to post on its forum that
this was an excuse to take it to take
down steven crowder and YouTube
basically caved to all of this now I
should point out again Carlos masa is
not a well-intentioned person policing
the public space Carlos masa is one of
the moral vile practitioners of
censorship so just about a month ago not
even a month ago like three weeks ago he
tweeted out milk shake them all about
anybody who disagrees with him milk
shake them all humiliate them in every
turn make them dread public organizing
Carlos masa
has also defended an Tifa he has a video
that has some 1.8 million views on
YouTube all about how an tyfa is totally
fine here he is talking about how we
shouldn't worry about an tyfa a violent
group that targets people for violence
it's an umbrella term for a group that
shows up a protest to confront neo-nazis
and white supremacists they dress in all
black they wear masks and they
occasionally engage in violence once
again and Tifa members attack peaceful
demonstrators the group's tactics and
appearance have garnered them a lot of
media attention over the past few months
America is waking up to the Menace of
and Tifa they're known as anti fun
they're also known for being violent but
for a group that's getting so much air
time for being violent and dangerous
they're not causing that much having and
people vary but they make up a
any part of the protests they show up at
oh is there nothing right so so this guy
who says that steven crowder has to be
banned for making mean jokes about him
that hurt his feelings and gave his
feelings of boo-boo steven crowder and
youtube have to ban you to have to ban
people now he's defending an Tifa he's
also tweeted out about religious people
you know he's not bigoted in any way
Carlos maza he police's bigotry except
for when he's talking about religious
people then he tweets out things like
this July 4th 2015
quote it's my religious beliefs is a
really convenient way of saying you're
not allowed to point out what an insane
loathsome bigot I am so if you're
religious and you disagree with Carlos
Massa on social values you're loathes
and bigoted now I mean the man really is
a true delight and obviously we should
take very seriously his contentions that
he is a victim and he's a deep victim in
America's public discourse so there's
only one problem with this with this
Carlos Mazda stuff and that is that
Crowder didn't actually violate any of
YouTube's policies like any of YouTube's
policies how do I know this because
YouTube says that he didn't violate any
of YouTube's policies in fact YouTube
put out like a full statement explaining
that they did not but that Crowder
didn't do anything to violate their
policy so here is what YouTube said
about Crowder
they said quote taking a harder look at
harassment there been a lot of questions
over the last few days about our
policies on harassment particularly
around to YouTube creators Carlos masa
and steven crowder these are important
issues and we'd like to provide more
details and context than is possible in
any one string of tweets now the reason
they to put out this statement is
because their original take on this was
Crowder didn't violate policies but also
we are going to demonetised him meaning
that when you watch a youtube video at
the beginning of each video there's
usually an ad the creators get a portion
of that ad money if you D monetize then
you take the money away from those
YouTube creators they D monetize Crowder
and then they made some excuses about
him selling some sort of offensive shirt
and this is why they're doing this and
then they shifted again they said what
really wasn't about the offensive shirt
it's about sort of the totality of
everything that Crowder has done so this
necessitated YouTube's putting out a
full statement you will see the
Orwellian nature of this statement in
just one second we'll talk about in a
second first let's talk about how hard
it is to find a new job it's really
rough sometimes to find a new job he's
got to post out a bunch of job boards
and you have to look through the
classifieds and all of that sort of
stuff
well what if in
you had your own personal recruiter to
help you find a better job now zip
recruiters technology can do that for
you just download the zip recruiter job
search app let it know what kind of jobs
you're interested in it's technology
starts doing the work for you
the zip recruiter app finds jobs you
like and then puts your profile in front
of employers who may be looking for
somebody just like you if an employer
likes your profile zip recruiter lets
you know so if you're interested in the
job you can then apply it's no wonder
that zip recur is the number one rated
job search app it works great for
employers it works great for employees I
mean we use the prakruti here at the
Daily wire and should people on this
show perform badly today I promise you
will be on zip recruiter and their app
tonight my listeners should download the
free zip recruiter job search app today
let the power of technology work for you
don't wait the sooner you download the
free zip recruiter job search app the
sooner it can help you find a better job
why be stuck at that job that you're out
because you don't have the time to look
for another one zip recruiter makes it
happen for you right now
go down that download that free zip
recruiter job search app right now
upgrade your job just as employers are
looking for great employees like you ok
so YouTube finally has to put together a
comprehensive statement explaining why
they have demonetized
why they have demonetized steven crowder
and here is what they say they say there
been a lot of questions over the last
few days about our policies on
harassment since YouTube started 14
years ago we have focused on providing a
platform where anyone can broadcast
themselves connect with people and share
their voices and their experiences with
the world this has brought a lot of good
like Jules E who founded the hashtag
smart brown girl movement to empower
women of color or matpat a gaming
creator who along with his fans and
others other creators raised over
$200,000 to combat mental illness but it
has also created many challenges one of
the most important issues we face is
around harassment we enforce our
policies here rigorously and regardless
of the creator in question in the first
quarter of 2019 we removed tens of
thousands of videos and accounts for
violation of our policies on cyber
bullying and harassment we also removed
hundreds of millions of comments many of
which were flagged and removed due to
harassment that said policies needs to
keep up with current problems so they're
saying you know we've done a pretty good
job of removing harassment but the way
we define harassment is somebody in
targeted fashion is trying to harm
somebody not somebody made a joke about
somebody hears and they continue by
explaining that said policies need to
keep up with current problems one
particular challenge we faced more and
more these
is creator on creator harassment it's an
issue that Susan addressed in her latest
creator letter we update our policies on
an ongoing basis to make sure they're
current just today we took another step
in our fight against hate speech and our
responsibility to reduce the spread of
harmful borderline content now we'll
talk about this in a second YouTube's
new policies are of course
extraordinarily vague they do not make
clear what their standard is I am fine
with a transparent standard so we all
know whether we wish to post on a forum
that bans certain types of speech or not
when I am NOT fine with is YouTube's
fuzzy line which is the same fuzzy line
apparently held by both Facebook and
Twitter as well they say as mentioned
one of our upcoming projects will
re-examine our harassment policy as well
as an open platform says YouTube we
sometimes host opinions and views that
many ourselves included may find
offensive these could include edgy
stand-up comedy routines a chart-topping
song or charged political rant and more
short moments from these videos placed
together paint a troubling picture but
individually they don't always cross the
lines this sounds like this is gonna be
a defensive Crowder because what maza
did is he took a bunch of clips over the
course of probably a year of Crowder's
program splice them together in a minute
25 and then suggested that Crowder is
attacking him every single day and
targeting for him for harassment not
just making jokes about videos that maza
has done himself and you can literally
do this for anybody right is not
difficult to go through any creators or
comedians content and splice together
some stuff that makes them look bad for
example it's not hard for me to make a
bunch of comedians look bad for ripping
president Trump in the most vile
possible way light like we could just do
this for example you talk like a sign
language gorilla who got hit in the head
in fact the only thing your mouth is
good for is being Vladimir Putin's
pollster you know Ivanka that's a
beautiful photo of you and your child
but let me just say one mother to
another do something about your dad's
immigration practices you feckless cop
and obviously I I hope India and
Pakistan don't go to war but if they did
go to war it'll probably be the most
entertaining war of all time
yeah because the Indian soldiers would
run out on the battlefield and that'd be
like time for yah
[Music]
get that get that get that get that get
that quick duck it can take a second
take my okay so you can do all that on
you it's not hard to clip these things
together is all that I'm saying it's not
hard to come up with clips from like
Stephen Colbert's show in which they
make a joke about Dana lash my friends
anal lash from the NRA getting shot
right it's not hard to find the liberal
media wants you to believe that the NRA
doesn't deserve it's nonprofit status
just because we make a profit but here's
the thing if you take away our
tax-exempt status how would we continue
our great charity work arming stray cats
who live on the mean streets isn't that
cinnamon it's funny see because you're
getting shot by a cat you know that that
sort of stuff is fine Family Guy making
gay jokes every five seconds making
ridiculous anti-jewish jokes I mean the
kind of humor that is used on Family Guy
with regard to Jews is about as close to
the line of anti-semitism as it is
possible to be without being considered
fully anti-semitic all that stuff is
fine I need to but it's not hard to find
this sort of content ever it's very easy
to find this sort of content and the
answer to it mostly is get over it the
answer to it unless it is somebody who
is publishing your home address
threatening you with death is grow a
thicker skin pansies but get over it and
that's true for everyone right that is
true for people on the right it is true
for people on the left it doesn't matter
I mean this is not a specific reference
to Carlos Mazda it's true for everyone
if you get hit and people are insulting
you and then you call for censorship
this is the problem now you can be
offended right you can get upset that's
understandable but you calling for
censorship from a tech company from a
social media company because you don't
like the people are making fun of you
yeah stop whining so YouTube but
basically acknowledges that they do not
actually have a rationale for going
after crowder their statement continues
there are two key policies at play here
harassment and hate speech for
harassment we look at whether the
purpose of the video is to incite
harassment threaten or humiliate an
individual or whether personal
information is revealed
we consider the entire video for example
is it a two-minute video dedicated to
going after an individual a 30 minute
video of political speech where
different individuals are called out a
handful of times is it focused on a
public or a private figure for hate
speech we look at whether the primary
purpose of the video is to incite hatred
toward or promote supremacism over a
protected group or whether it seeks to
incite violence to be clear using racial
homophobic or sexist epithets on their
own would not necessarily violate either
of these policies for example as noted
above lewd or offensive language is
often used in songs and comedic routines
it's when the primary purpose of the
video is hate or harassment and when
videos violate these policies we remove
them now it is true that steven crowder
did not engage in either harassment or
hate speech by these standards he did
not intend to incite harassment or
threaten or humiliate an individual he
made a couple of jokes over the course
of a year maybe seven or eight jokes
over the course of a year about Carlos
Mazda being gay and Latino hey that may
not be funny to you you may not like
those jokes you may find those jokes
offensive that does not constitute
harassment and it certainly does not
constitute hate speech the purpose of
the video was not to incite violence
tour to promote supremacism over Latinos
or gay folks so YouTube basically
acknowledges this they say not everyone
will agree with the calls we make some
will say we haven't done enough others
will say we've gone too far sometimes a
decision to leave an offensive video on
the site will look like us defending
people who have used their platforms and
audiences to bullied to mean marginalize
or ignore others if we were to take all
potentially offensive content down we'd
be losing valuable speech speech that
allows people everywhere to raise their
voices tell their stories question those
in power and participate in the critical
cultural and political conversations of
our day and here's where you get to the
crux of the matter and this is so
incredible it's so incredible because
YouTube basically now goes full or well
now they go basa that they just shift
the meaning of words they change the
meaning of language and they effectively
admit they have no rationale for D
monetizing crowder or censoring people
and yet they're gonna do it anyway if
people yell at them aloud enough that's
not really in that enact an inaccurate
cement synopsis of what they say in this
following paragraph quote even if they
creators content doesn't violate our
Community Guidelines we will take a look
at the broader context and impact and if
their behavior is egregious and harms
the broader community we may take acts
hey what do those words even mean those
are words that have no meaning if a
creators content doesn't violate our
Community Guidelines we will still take
a look at the broader context and impact
what the hell does that mean okay you're
gonna look at Bernie Sanders this video
take into account the fact that somebody
who liked Bernie Sanders shot up a bunch
of Congress people no well you know
there's a broader context and impact I
guess you've got to take down Bernie
Sanders now in the case of Crowder's
channel says YouTube a thorough review
over the weekend found that individually
the flag videos did not violate our
community guidelines all right so he
should be done here right no wrong do
you are in a second I will explain how
YouTube then openly engages in the
hecklers veto and makes room for people
yelling at them to effectively change
YouTube's internal policy but first with
the ever increasing numbers of car makes
and models it's now impossible to stock
all the parts you need in traditional
chain store front have you ever gone to
one of these auto parts stores and you
need a particular price and then you
have to endure pointless ridiculous
questions like is your Odyssey in LX or
Annie X and then you wait while the
counterman orders the parts on its
computer and then it turns out he only
has like one type of part on the
computer well here's the good news you
have a computer and that computer has
access to the Internet and the Internet
has access to Rock auto comm at home and
in your pocket Rock Auto comm is a
family business they've served Auto
Parts customers online for 20 years go
to Rock Auto comm shop for auto and body
parts from hundreds of manufacturers
they have everything from engine control
modules and brake parts to tail lamps
motor oil even new carpet whether it's
for your classic or daily driver get
everything you need and a few easy
clicks delivered directly to your door
if amazing selection reliably low prices
all the parts your car is ever gonna
need
Rock Auto calm so go check them out
right now Rock Auto calm see all the
parts available for your car or truck
right shapiro in there how did you hear
about us box so that they know that we
sent you and then make sure that you
shop at rockauto.com because again why
would you go to a store that doesn't
have the parts that you need and a more
expensive price instead go check out
Rock Auto calm right now okay in just a
second I'm going to show you how YouTube
has destroyed its own standards in the
name of the leftist hecklers veto first
you need to go subscribe so today I need
to make a special subscriber pitch okay
here's the deal the reason you need to
subscribe to the show is not just
because you get all the additional
benefits the two additional hours of me
in the afternoon
or because you want for some odd reason
Michael Knowles's show or even because
for $99 you get this the very greatest
in beverage vessels the leftist leaders
hot or cold tumbler the real reason that
you need to subscribe is because there
are militant nasty bad people out there
people like Carlos Massa who are intent
every day and tearing down our capacity
to disseminate a message with which they
disagree there are people like Media
Matters every day who are watching this
show just looking for excuses to try and
get social media companies to penalize
us or to go after our advertisers and to
attack our advertisers every day there
are folks in the mainstream media who
are scheming to try and disrupt the
dissemination of information with which
they do not agree they've done this to
not just me they've done this deceivin
Crowder they've done it's Tucker Carlson
they've done it to Laura Ingraham at
them enshrine Hannity they've done it to
Rush Limbaugh
if it unto everyone everyone who is
remotely right-of-center and doesn't
even have to be somebody who is openly
Republican they've done this to Dave
Rubin they've done this to they've done
it to Jordan Peterson they will try to
do it to Joe Rogan every creator that
you like is under the gun from the
leftist woke scold who are interested
not in an exchange of ideas but in
shutting down ideas they don't like
you'll notice that the tumbler that we
give you with this subscription is the
leftist here's how to call tumblr you
know you notice what it doesn't say I
insisted on this really it does not say
liberal tears the reason it does not say
liberal tears is because I said I would
not sell a mug that said upon it liberal
tears why because liberals and leftists
are not the same liberals are people
with whom I disagree on tax rates and
social policy and the role of government
leftists are people who want to shut
down the debate because they believe
that the only way to reorder society is
to prevent people from speaking freely
who disagree with them the only way to
fight those people is to directly
monetize the shows that you like so I'm
not just going to encourage you to
subscribe to daily wire today so that
you can ensure that our content is
brought direct to you and that we can't
be shut off by the youtubes of the world
or the Facebook's of the world or the
Twitter's of the world and ensure that
if people go after our advertisers we
can still continue to function listen we
have great advertisers there are folks
who advertise on a wide range of
programs they don't agree with
everything that we say and that's fine
that's good I don't think they should
only advertise on shows with which they
agree we have great advertisers but the
fact is that
les has tried to intimidate advertisers
into pulling money out of programs that
they don't like instead of just saying
don't watch Shapiro if you don't like
Shapiro they go after people who
advertise on the program deliberately in
order to prevent anybody from being able
to monetize content that they don't like
in order preventing advertisers from
being able to reach you the audience
well the way to make sure that we can
continue bringing you the content that
you actually want is to subscribe so
today don't just subscribe to daily
we're calm go over and subscribe to
blaze TV go over and subscribe to Fox
Nation go over and subscribe to Joe
Rogan subscribe to Dave Rubin subscribe
to anybody who's content you like
because your contribution to them
ensures that they do not have to worry
as much about the possibility of their
livelihood being taken away from them by
nasty cusses who believe that if they
are mildly offended they get to change
the rules of debate so please go
subscribe right now also I will note
that when you subscribe you do get all
these great benefits you get all sorts
of great stuff we have a fantastic
Sunday special this Sunday with senator
Ted Cruz who stopped by for the full
hour as Larry King would say in our
house you know it wasn't that politics
was something to just kind of read the
paper and oh that's interesting
I mean there was an urgency to it it was
having principled men and women in
office that's how you protect yourself
from tyranny and and so that's what I
wanted to do my whole life
so the show is really good Ted's a
really interesting guy when you get
behind the scenes with them he's even
more an interesting guy than he is very
often on camera I think that this is a
pretty good interviewing interview or he
covered a lot of ground you can go check
that out listen we're working hard to
bring you a contents every day we really
appreciate you subscribing it really
does make the difference for us go over
and subscribe $9.99 a month $99 a year
over at daily wire.com also make sure
that you do watch us over at YouTube or
iTunes you know thank God we're still
available on youtube so please
disseminate our videos widely make sure
that people actually see them because
this is part of how you exercise your
right to free speech we are the largest
fastest-growing conservative podcast and
radio show in the nation
[Music]
you
all right so back to YouTube's actual
final word here so they note openly that
Crowder does not violate their Community
Guidelines and then they get to the
punchline quote however in the
subsequent days we saw the widespread
harm to the YouTube community resulting
from the ongoing pattern of egregious
behavior took a deeper look and made the
decision to suspend monetization in
order to be considered for reinstatement
all relevant issues with the channel
need to be addressed including any
videos that violate our policies as well
as things like offensive merchandise in
the coming months we'll be taking a hard
look at our harassment policies with an
aim to update them just as we have to so
many policies over the years in
consultation with experts creators
journalists and those who have
themselves been victims of harassment we
are determined to evolve our policies
and continue to hold our creators and
ourselves to a higher standard so in
other words Crowder didn't violate their
standards so we're gonna create new
standards and the new standards is if
you enough then we'll change our
rules if you whine enough then we'll
change our rules and we'll go
specifically after creators you don't
like the squeaky wheel gets the grease
is the new YouTube rule on harassment so
it doesn't matter if somebody was just
making a joke about you if I do it Chris
Matthews impersonation and he gets mad
and then he whines about it to YouTube
presumably YouTube will then take it
take a look at the widespread harm to
the YouTube community resulting from the
ongoing pattern of egregious behavior
this is what they'll couldn't could it
get any bigger than that by the way they
can't explain why a single video
violates the policy but it's the it's
the widespread harm how do they measure
the widespread harm hmm how is that
measured because I don't see the metric
when they say widespread harms they mean
we got a lot of phone calls because if
so who cares or lots of people tweeted
things about us woo-hoo-hoo-hoo I'm sure
they were all gonna stop using YouTube
I'm sure that there was gonna be a
massive revenue hit from creators who
stopped using YouTube and started going
to Vimeo from people who love Carlos
Mazel yeah I'm sure that was the big
what was the widespread harm where their
streets filled with pitchfork wielding
anti-gay anti Latino protesters who are
attempting to harm gay and Latino people
across the land because steven crowder
made a few jokes about carlos maza where
was the huge harm I mean this is wimp
crap it really is and not just on the
part of Carlos mom
but on the part of YouTube the YouTube
creators I have very little faith in our
social media tech overlords to do the
right thing here if they're going to
cave like this is very reminiscent of
what's been happening on college
campuses where college campuses just
deny invites to people who are part of
the mainstream discourse because a bunch
of people whine about it and suggest
that they're gonna get mad
the whiniest people in America are now
running the ship when it comes to big
tech and social media and free
marketeers like me who are against
censorship not only on social media but
censorship of social media people who
don't want to see government come in and
regulate companies like YouTube or
Facebook or Twitter I believe these are
private companies now people like me are
going to be pushed into the hard
position of having to decide whether
section 230 of the Communications
Decency Act ought to be changed or the
Communications Act whether that whether
that Act ought to be changed
specifically to make a harder
distinction between publishers and
platforms whether or not if YouTube is
now going to be a publisher meaning they
are going to censor everything that goes
up in the same way that I censor things
that go up on my website if this is
their role maybe they shouldn't be given
the same sort of legal exemptions as an
AT&T on a phone line because we're now
edging into territory where without any
clear standard web any transparency this
sort of Star Chamber is Ted Cruz's
called it love social media can decide
on a backfilled rationale to simply D
monetize things how unclear are these
standards by the way they're so unclear
that a bunch of people who were
reporting on white supremacy have now
been banned from YouTube's who one guy's
name is Ford Fisher he's an independent
journalist and co-founder of news
Teixeira calm he covers fringe political
events he is not engaged in white
supremacy he reports on it his account
was basically banned okay and then
Carlos Muslim whined about it why can't
you tube just Baron crowd or why are
they banning people why I like to well
maybe because once you call for
censorship that cat is out of the bag
this one's on you buddy it's amazing to
watch as all of our journalistic
firefighters rush to defend YouTube's
action here we'll get to more of this in
just one second and the journalistic
firefighters are defending this sort of
action
BuzzFeed says YouTube has begun blocking
discriminating content just a day
Nitori content just a day after saying
it doesn't violate its policies Ryan
Broderick who's policing this thing all
day one of the things you'll notice
about a lot of the journalists so-called
journalists from BuzzFeed or Vox or any
of these others supposed journalistic
institutions is what they do is they use
journalism to hide their activism so for
example any time a show like Tucker
Carlson's or Laura Ingram's or my shows
attacked one of the things that you will
see is huffington post immediately go
seeking khan's comment from advertisers
the reason they are doing this is not
because they actually need a comment
from advertisers the reason they are
doing this is because they are
deliberately trying to foster a story
that advertisers support my speech or
Tucker speech or Laura's speech or Sean
Hannity speech or anybody else's speech
they're trying to say that if an
advertiser advertised on both this
podcast and pod save America is not that
they're trying to reach a diverse
audience of people who disagree on a lot
of issues no it must be that they are
specifically endorsing my positions on
the issues and that's a great vly it's a
tremendous lie but the reason that
Huffington Post will reach out to the
advertisers is to say do you really want
to support that message now what
advertisers should say and many do as
they should is we advertise on a wide
range of programs we don't agree with
everything Shapiro says just as we don't
agree with everything on pod save
America we're a Kimble brand right we
sell dog food all we want to do is reach
customers but the purpose of these media
hit artists is to go after the
advertisers to destroy the very way that
it's possible to bring these programs to
you in the first place they've done this
to talk radio routinely for years one of
the so-called journalists doing this
yesterday was Ryan Broderick who was
keeping a running tally of all the
YouTube creators who had been blocked in
quasi celebratory fashion
and then he writes this up for BuzzFeed
news YouTube announced Wednesday will
prohibit videos that promote
discrimination or segregation based on
things like age gender race caste
religion sexual orientation and veteran
status by the way I have serious doubts
that anti-christian content on YouTube
is going to suddenly be blocked orgy
monetized and YouTube is so mad answered
questions like okay if there's a pastor
who talks about natural law and same-sex
marriage is that person going to be
blocked but according to BuzzFeed news
the announcement comes just a day after
the video platform was criticized for
how it handles anti-gay content
thousands of
are expected to be affected by the
policy change shortly note one guy
complained thousands of creators will be
affected now perhaps we have gone too
far in the direction of taking into
account people's feelings people's
feelings
we should have told these people to call
the wambulance instead we have our tech
overlords catering to them it's pathetic
the announcement identified several
kinds of videos that will now be
prohibited on the platform they say this
would include for example videos that
promote or glorify Nazi ideology which
is inherently discriminatory finally we
will remove content to nine that well
documented violence events like the
Holocaust or the shooting at Sandy Hook
elementary took place according to
YouTube as the policy started to take
effect on Wednesday creators chaotically
started tweeting screenshots of emails
from YouTube notifying them they were in
violation of the new policy as a bunch
of folks who have been hit by this
including Jesse Lee Peterson who is a
conservative black minister Gavin
McInnes had videos removed from his
channel kallen Killa had video's removed
from his channel YouTube is starting at
the fringes and then they are moving
more into sort of the mainstream of
views that they don't like so they start
with the people who it's harder to
defend and then they move toward people
whom it is easier to defend
BuzzFeed reports the rollout of
YouTube's new policy has been wildly
confusing to say the least the Google
owned video platform first announced
that it would be de monetizing Crowder's
channel on Wednesday in a tweet the
platform said Crowder would no longer be
able to run ads on his channel due to a
pattern of egregious accounts that has
harmed the broader community YouTube
later clarified the Crowder's channel
would have the ad restrictions removed
if he deleted a link to t-shirts he was
selling that red socialism is for bleeps
okay bleeps is the effort for gay people
but that's not what the shirt doesn't
actually say that it says socialism is
for FIGS there's a picture of a pig in
the middle of the word just a day
earlier YouTube had said that Crowder's
near constant harassment of Mazda did
not violate his policy love this near
constant harassment Crowder puts out
hours of content every day over the
course of the year he mentioned miles in
probably ten times you cut that together
and it's now near constant harassment
and now it's gonna get worse YouTube
says in January
we've here's where it's here's where all
of this is going okay and here's why the
left cares about all this they don't
care about the soap supposed harassment
of Carlos massa
they don't care about the
posing mean jokes that that create an
aura and emanation from a penumbra of
harm here's what they really care about
what they really care about is making
YouTube into a functionary of the
mainstream media this is what they
actually want here's what YouTube has
says quote in January we've highlighted
an up piloted an update of our systems
in the United States to limit
recommendations of borderline content
and harmfulness information such as
videos promoting a phony miracle cure
for a serious illness or claiming the
earth is flat we're looking to bring at
this updated system to more countries by
the end of 2019 and then they say that
they are moving toward videos from
authoritative sources YouTube says it
also plans to make videos from
authoritative sources appear higher up
in its watch next panel so instead of
their algorithm recommending videos that
you might like so if you watch a video
of me you might end up in a video of
Jordan Peterson or vice versa instead
then we want videos from our Thorat ativ
sources which lots of authoritative
sources mean let's think
you think maybe YouTube is gonna benefit
like you know some of the podcast that
it likes like The Young Turks or maybe
they will benefit box or maybe they'll
benefit BuzzFeed maybe their
authoritative sources will be you know
the New York Times and CNN but not
anything from Fox News of course social
media is being prepped for 20/20 in the
end that's what this is all about this
is not about making a better public
square this is not about cleansing the
public square of things that make people
feel icky this is simply about YouTube
and Facebook and Twitter
knowing that come 2020 the blowback from
the Democrats is going to be extreme if
people are allowed to express their
views you've already seen it Nancy
Pelosi has already set blame Facebook
said Facebook was willing willing
participants in Russian propaganda in
2016 all the social media tech pros are
coming together to put together a plan
that basically says if it's anywhere not
to the left it is no longer
authoritative watch for content to be
downgraded we're watching a ground shift
in the openness of social media
platforms in the internet it is
politically driven it is obvious than it
is politically driven it is not an
honest standard being applied it's not
even transparent it's obvious what is
happening right here and so the solution
is going to be the building of
alternatives and you subscribing at
places like Daily wire outlets you
actually care about because pretty soon
these tech companies
and a knuckle under because frankly they
agree with the political priorities of
the people criticizing them so why would
they stand up for the political
priorities of people who don't even if
it violates their supposed free speech
principles okay time for some things I
like and then some things that I hate so
things that I like today so there is a
great movie that I reference a little
bit earlier in the week called
Sullivan's Travels the Preston Sturges
movie Joel McCrea and Veronica Lake
who's just charming in the extreme my
wife and I've been on an old movies kick
so last night we watched another old
movie born yesterday which is just a
terrific film Sullivan's Travels is
really great the basic premise is that
Joel McCrea is a director who is sick of
producing comedies that people like to
watch and now he wants to produce an
important film and so he decides to go
out into the country and do research for
this very important film about income
and equality and poverty and what he
realizes that maybe he should stick to
his lane because his lane makes people
happy and there's nothing wrong with
that here's a little bit of the trailer
without friends without credit without
checkbooks without Dave experience and
gets more than he bargained for the next
corner and take this bus back where he
stole a front don't talk nonsense I left
a note saying I was taking the car
[Music]
be nice if you can remember
suppose that is well whatever it is
there's absolutely nothing they can do
remember that the movie is the movies
really terrific it's well worth watching
it again it's a reminder that Hollywood
used to be a little bit more self-aware
Hollywood used to recognize that maybe
the social justice warrior kind of stuff
is not their mandate and the movie is
well worth watching Sullivan's Travels
it's also the source of need the George
Clooney Coen Brothers movie o brother
where art thou that's the name of the
movie that that Joel McRae's director
wants to create oh brother where art
thou okay time for a couple of things
that I hate so I'm not sure the last
time that David Crosby was relevant
apparently he was a singer at one point
a little bit old for me I guess
but in any case he got a letter from a
woman who said that her husband voted
for Trump they've been married for like
40 years so he recommended they get
divorced yeah there's nothing wrong with
the lefty brain at this point for 40
years and I love him dearly he's a good
man and a good husband my only problem
is he's become a die-hard Trump
supporter dun dun Dada he's driving to
me completely insane naturally how can
any otherwise rational man support that
would it be crazy and my marriage
over political differences I feel your
pain the guy's a snake oil salesman it's
a scam you have to be pretty stupid to
buy it so I can't say any positive stuff
about your husband you might want to be
looking around for somebody else okay
maybe he's half joking maybe he's not
that's a ridiculous statement now I've
always said that people should marry
people who share values and very often
values means sharing politics but if
you've been married 40 years and you
probably have kids and grandkids
together the fact that your husband and
you disagree about Donald Trump I think
it's pretty bad excuse to break up a
marriage okay other things that I hate
today so Nancy Pelosi told Democrats
apparently behind closed doors that she
wants to see President Trump in prison
she says that she clashed apparently
with House Judiciary Chairman Jerry
Nadler she met with Nadler and several
other top Democrats who are aggressively
pursuing investigations Nadler press
Pelosi to allow his committee to launch
an impeachment inquiry against Trump she
said no she said she's not opens the
idea of impeaching Trump at this time
she said I don't want to see him
impeached I want to see him in prison
which of course is somewhat mutually
exclusive since
will not end up in prison at the hands
of Democrats unless he actually ends up
losing his job instead of impeachment
Pelosi still prefers to see Trump
defeated at the ballot box and then
prosecuted for his alleged crimes I love
how the Democrats have moved from it is
evil for the President of the United
States work for the a candidate for
president to say about another candidate
lock her up so terrible so evil so awful
and there she is telling people that she
wants to lock up Donald Trump what what
did the light she is I mean she's just
she sounds like a charmer okay other
things that I hate final thing that I
hate today so I have a lot of respect
for Tucker Carlson I think the Tucker
Carlson is a smart guy I think that his
that he's really really talented he and
I disagree in very significant way about
economics so a couple of days ago maybe
yesterday we discussed Elizabeth
Warren's economic plans and I talked
about hadam they were because
essentially they call for higher tariffs
greater government expenditures autarky
an attempt to bring manufacturing back
to the country by taxing American
citizens subsidies massive government
intervention here's where Tucker and I
disagree Tucker thinks Elizabeth Warren
is on the right track we can navigate
the changes ahead if we embrace economic
patriotism and make American workers our
highest priority rather than continuing
to cater to the interests of companies
and people with no allegiance to America
the words you just heard are from
embrace yourself here senator Elizabeth
Warren of Massachusetts it's true
yesterday Warren released what she
called her plan for economic patriotism
amazingly that's pretty much what it is
economic patriotism is just pure
old-fashioned economics how to preserve
good-paying American jobs she sounds
like Donald Trump at his best
okay so no no she does not sound like
Donald Trump as best she sounds like
Donald Trump it is worse because that's
a bunch of pandering crap you're not
going to make American industry great
again through tariffs and subsidies and
Tucker is a big government
interventionist when it comes to certain
political priorities and then he goes so
far as to suggest that American
Republicans are libertarians and
governments and sort of Libertines when
it comes to social policy I'm not seeing
the evidence of that at all considering
that Republicans are spending like
drunken sailors on shore leave I mean
the Republican the Republican Party are
spending at exorbitant rates they are
not scaling back regulation at nearly
the pace that libertarians want if you
this republican party's libertarian i
would urge you to look at their actual
record it has not been libertarian in
the slightest if tucker is agreeing with
elizabeth warren i think a good rule of
thumb is if you agree with elizabeth
warren you're probably wrong
so again i think this goes to Tucker's
view of the economy if you're more
interested in sort of that debate tucker
and i had this very broad ranging
discussion on the sunday especially and
go back and listen to that episode
because we covered some of the same
topics suffice it to say that while
tucker and I agree on the social dangers
of the left and the left priorities i
don't think that seizing the ring of
power that his government is likely to
cure all of those ills nor do i think
that growing the government for the
benefit of certain folks at the expense
of other folks is either good policy or
in traditional classical liberal and
classically American economic history
alrighty we'll be back here a little bit
later today with two additional hours I
want to remind you please go subscribe
it helps insulate us against the
stupidities and censorship of left go do
that over at daily wire.com we'll see
you here tomorrow i'm ben shapiro this
is the ben shapiro show
the Ben Shapiro show is produced by
Robert Sterling directed by Mike joiner
executive producer Jeremy boring senior
producer Jonathan hey our supervising
producer is Mathis Glover and our
technical producer is Austin Stevens
edited by Adam Savitz audio is mixed by
Mike Cora Mena hair and makeup is by
Jesuit alvera production assistant Nick
Sheehan the Ben Shapiro show is a daily
wire production copyright daily weiter
2019 hey everyone its Andrew Clavin host
of the Andrew Clavin show d-day was 75
years ago today and for all the
sentimental remembrances and heartfelt
tributes it's virtually impossible to
recapture or convey the scale and scope
of the heroism and sacrifice that was
required to begin the rollback of the
Nazi conquest you have to ask yourself
could we do it today would we why did
they fight why did they win and have we
lost what it takes to pull off that kind
of monumental triumph talk about it on
the Andrew Clavin show I'm Andrew Clavin